شهدت المنطقه الشرقيه في السعوديه اقامه
اول معرضا للكتاب تنظمه هيئه الادب والنشر
والترجمه ضمن مهرجان الكتاب والكراب او
الكتاب عفوا والقراء ويستمرون مع رضا
شرقيه للكتاب حتى الحادي عشر من مارس
الجري يعقد المعرض بشركه ثقافيه مع مركز
الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء
وبمشاركه اكثر من 500 ناشر محلي وعربي
ودولي فضلا عن اقامه نحو 140 فعاليه ضمن
برنامج ثقافيا خاص
معنى من مراسل او معنى من معرض الشرقيه
للكتاب مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العاصي
عبد الرحمن حياك الله
هذا هو معرض الكتاب اذا في الشرقيه لكن
كان يشوف الاقبال ضعيف
لا بالعكس خالد يعني اهل الشرقيه متعطشين
جدا لهذا المعرض الذي غاب عنهم كثيرا
واخيرا اقيم معرض الشرقيه لكتاب طبعا هذا
المعرض ياتي ضمن مهرجان الكتاب والقراء في
المنطقه الشرقيه الذي يشمل العديد من
الفعاليات يعني الاسبوع الاول كان فعاليات
ثقافيه في ثلاث مواقع الدمام وكرنيش الخبر
وايضا كورنيش القطيف
ثم بدا يوم الخميس قبل يومين معرض الكتاب
لنتحدث اكثر خالد عن هذا المعرض وابرز
الارقام وابرز الفعاليات والبرامج
الثقافيه الموجوده في انضم الي الرئيس
التنفيذي لهيئه الادب والنشر تجربه
الدكتور محمد حسن علوان اهلا دكتور محمد
نتكلم بدايه عن مهرجان الكتاب والقراء
ياتي بشكل مختلف لماذا الكتاب والقراء
ولماذا يعني تم تجهيز تجزئه المهرجان جزء
مهرجانات فعاليه بالهواء طلق وجزء معرض
كتاب
طبعا الكتاب والقران انهم من الطرفين
الاساسيين في هذه العلاقه التاريخيه
الثقافيه التي محورها الكتاب المهرجان
اقيم في عده مواقع كما تفضلت وكان الهدف
منه ان نمحور فعاليات الثقافيه حول هذه
العلاقه ولكن بالتنويع في
طبيعه
الفعاليات الثقافيه متنوعه كانت فنون
ادائيه وكان فيها ايضا مسرحيات وكان فيها
عروض كوميديا وكان فيها ايضا
مساحات متاحه لدور النشر والمكتبات لعرض
منتجاتها الثقافيه وايضا للمنتجات الاهالي
اي انها كانت فعاليه اجتماعيه في المقام
الاول
يراد منها ان
ندعو اهالي المنطقه
للاحتفال
بالكتاب وبالقراء وبالمنتج الاساسي الناتج
منهما وهو الكتاب زميلي خالد قبل شوي يقول
الاقبال كانه ضعيف
دكتور يعني كيف شفتوا الاقبال خلال اول
ثلاثه ايام من المهرجان وايضا ابرز الدور
المشاركه اعدادها ابرز الدول المشاركه في
المهرجان لا ما نشوف الرقبه ضعيف عذرا
استاذ خالد
لكن المعرض كبير الحجم مساحات كبيره جدا
او موزعه فيها
دور النشر على 4 قاعات كبرى هناك قاعه
اضافيه اضفناها للمعرض
للاستجابه للطلب العالي من دور النشر
السعوديه والحمد لله المساحات مشغوله منذ
الصباح منذ افتتاح المعرض من الصباح وحتى
اقفال المعرض وعدد الزوار لا يتوقف ان
يعني زياره المعرض
وايضا يعني المشاركه في انشطه البرنامج
الثقافي دكتور مهرجان الثقافي المصاحب
للمهرجان الاسماك كبيره مهمه
روائيين ايضا كتاب شعراء ايضا شعر نبطي
نتكلم عن ابرز ملامح هذا البرنامج الثقافي
نعم حرصنا في ذلك ان يكون البرنامج ننوع
كما ذكرت واريد ان انتهز هذه الفرصه
واتقدم بالشكر الجزيل للشريك الثقافي
الوحيد لهذا المعرض وهو مركز الملك عبد
العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء الذين قاموا
باعداد البرنامج الثقافي وتكفل بذلك وهو
كما يعني لاحظتم كان على مستوى ما هو
متوقع من اثراء الذين اعتدنا منهم دائما
الابداع والحراك الثقافي الرسين والفاعل
والمؤثر الحمد لله البرنامج في ثلاث ايام
الاولى حظي باقبال كبير من
الزوار وايضا كان هناك ورش عمل يعني
حارسنا انها
متنوعه في في مجالات مختلفه وقدموها لنا
مركز الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي العالمي
بكل ما يمكن ان نتوقع منهم من ابداع وحرص
على
استيفاء جميع معايير الجوده وتلبيه رغبات
الزوار ايضا لاحظت الطفل له نصيبه من هذا
المعرض له نصيب كبير جدا ونحن مستمرون في
زياده المساحات المخصصه للطفل في جميع
معارض الكتاب في المملكه لايماننا الكبير
بانه الطفل هو
يعني جزء لا يتجزا من حراك الثقافي هو
ايضا مستقبل الثقافه وايضا هناك العديد
مما يمكن ان نقدمه للطفل مما يحوله الى
زائر دائم لمعارض الكتاب باذن الله في
المستقبل
الفعاليات الموجهه للطفل ليست فعاليات
ترفيهيه فقط بل هي فعاليه فعاليه ثقافيه
هادفه الى اكتشاف المواهب الى خلق او خلق
هذه الحاله الابداعيه لدى الطفل بذره
الاستكشاف وايضا
يعني تجسير اللي هو المحتمل بين الطفل
وبين عالم الثقافه بوصفه عالما عالما يعني
فيه الكثير من المتعه شكرا جزيلا دكتور
محمد
خالد يعني كما راينا فعلا معرض متنوع جدا
ومهرجان كبير جدا حفلات موسيقيه ايضا
موجوده طوال ليالي المهرجان اقبال من جميع
الفئات العمريه ايضا من حسن حظ المعرض ان
هذا الاسبوع اسبوعي اجازه بالنسبه للطلاب
في الاقبال سيزيد اكثر فاكثر مع مرور
الايام شكرا